[Music]
this plane is
the super canard look at the design on
this guy two sets of wings you got a
forward wing get a rear wing here
by angling the forward wing at a
slightly higher angle of incidence than
the main wing
that is just tilting it up a little bit
you can see the bends right there
in that forward wing i'm tilting it up
just a little bit with these upward
bends
two things cause a stall too high an
angle of incidence
or too slow of a speed now obviously if
the plane's flying too slow
you just don't develop enough air flow
that will
have the coanda effect to stick to the
surface of the wing it's just going so
slow
that the airflow just kind of fails to
form over the wing no lift
plane falls out of the sky the other
thing is that if you're angling too
far upward with this wing here
eventually it can't follow around the
shape of the wing the airflow becomes
disconnected and again we call that a
stall the airflow you need air flow
trailing off the back of the plane to
shove the plane up to make lift
so those are the two ways that your
plane can lose lift
with a stall too slow or too high an
angle of incidence so what we do with
this plane is really kind
of clever we angle this little wing a
little bit higher angle of incidence
than the main wing so when it gets close
to stalling
the little wing will stall first drop
the nose down and the main wing keeps
flying
so it's a stall resistant paper airplane
one of the really cool features of this
plane
is that it starts with a modified
version of a
classic paper airplane base called a
water bomb base i want to show you that
base
and then i'll walk you through the
folding of the super canard here but the
water bomb base idea
very powerful you can make all kinds of
planes with the water bomb base
you can make this starfighter design
starts with a water bomb base this
really cool double decker plane it's
called
the uh interlock biplane
it starts with a modified water bomb
base water bomb base idea
the twin jet starts with a water bomb
base straight up water bomb base no
modified
water bomb base that's a straight water
bomb base idea and this guy
starts with a slightly modified water
bomb base what
the heck is a water bomb base i've said
it so many times you must be
going crazy okay so i'm going to start
by making diagonal bolts taking the top
and putting it against the side
first this way and again i like to hold
down the corner
pivot those edges together and then
sweep
make a nice clean fold unfold that i'm
going a little bit fast don't feel like
you got to follow along on this
uh necessarily i just want to show you
the mechanics of this thing
i'm lining up this corner lining up that
edge
sweeping down nice sharp creases
now we've got what you would call valley
folds because they look like valleys
when viewed from above
let's flip our valleys over so that
they're mountains both of my diagonal
folds are now mountains
i'm going to fold right across the
center
of that x and carefully line up the ends
of the creases
and then i'm going to walk slowly up
here find a center sweep that direction
sweep that direction
make a nice sharp crease there
and then i'm going to open this up and
i'm going to stand it up so that this
fold that we just
created is now a mountain fold and flip
it around so the short side is on top
the x is now on the top of the page
again
so we were here and i'm really flipping
it over
and just opening it up a little bit and
making a little tunnel you can see i can
i can
go right under there now very few things
happen
fast in origami and this is one of the
cool
fast happening things with just three
creases we're gonna make
one of the all-time best bases for
creating paper airplanes
and we're gonna do it just like this i'm
going to take one finger and press down
right where all those creases meet
very gently just until the paper pops
you can see it pop change directions
there and then
i'm going to bring the top down and let
the sides come in
and that is a water bomb base let's
tighten it just a little bit
it fills the screen now look at what
you've got here for making a paper
airplane you've got these two corners
here you can turn into
tunnels in the front of the plane like i
did with the with the twin jet
so you've got a delta shape happening
here which gives you less lift
up front there's a ton of layers you've
got four good solid layers up front
and so along with having a delta shape
and multiple layers
moving toward the front of the plane
you're uh you're off to a great running
start
for developing paper airplanes this is
the super canard
and to start folding this guy we'll need
one sheet of eight and a half by eleven
paper
i prefer twenty pound paper the first
time through a project like this a lot
of serious folding so let's get going
let's spin it
we have the long side on top and we're
going to fold it in half
carefully line up the corners and as
usual when we're folding in half line
the corners up start in the middle sweep
to the outside
just like that nice sharp crease
now we're going to fold one third of the
paper over and the way you measure that
you're just going to eyeball this
the layered part here is going to be the
same size as the unlayered part here
so get it close line it up make sure
your layers are staying together up here
don't let the layers go dripping around
keep those corners together as you bring
it over
and this part is going to be about the
same size as that part
and it doesn't have to be perfect just
get it as close as you can
eyeballing make a nice sharp crease i'm
going to spin it around now
so that the open part is toward me and
we're going to do a series of what are
called
squash folds and the only mistake you
can make with a squash fold is actually
trying to do it too fast
so let's see what's going on with the
squash fold here first
so we're going to open this up lift this
up so it's pointed right straight
up at us and we're gonna open the bottom
two layers here
put your finger all the way in there so
it gets all the way to the top so this
whole thing is starting to
squeeze down and we're gonna move the
top down taking care to line up the
center crease
with the center layer here so this
center crease
is going to line up with this center
layer right here and
i'm going to move the crease just to the
left side
of this center layer just to give me a
little room
to manipulate here and did i do that a
lot
just a little it's a little tiny bit of
a cheat just to make sure i've got room
to manipulate layers
not really a cheat it's just the proper
way to fold
so that's a squash fold we've taken this
flap
and it was sticking up like that and
we're squashing it
reaching inside starting to move the
layers to the outside and moving it down
and squashing it flat like that now
we're going to do the same thing
to the back side here
and so let's flip it over
and we're going to lift this layer up
and again we're going to open up the
open layers here put your finger all the
way in there so it starts to
open up now at this point you can't see
the layers
underneath right you're kind of it's
you're blocking so
once you get it going the correct
direction pro tip here flip it over now
you can control these two layers on top
move them down so that they line up with
that center crease
we're going to complete the squash from
the opposite side you would normally
complete a squash fold from
but you're going to make a much more
accurate crease
i worked up to the top sweeping down to
the bottom
and now you can see you've got a water
bomb like base
and we're not done with squash folds
each one of these flaps
one two three four it's going to get
squash folded so let's get going on that
move that one to the move the right hand
flap to the left
i'm gonna press down and carefully line
up
this crease with the center crease here
squash fold there
okay so let's open this up a little bit
more sometimes it's convenient to use a
pen to reach up in there if you've got a
pen handy that's a good thing to do
i'm just going to reach up in there with
my finger and open that up a little bit
more press that down
i want the squash to go neatly all the
way to the top so
again the only mistake you can really
make with a squash fold is doing it
too fast before everything is lined up
get my
crease just lined up with the center
crease perfectly there i've got it
squashed
controlled the layers and now i'm just
going to move this top flap
back to the left and now we're going to
squash this side so i'm lifting that up
opening it up carefully positioning that
crease so
the squash so it ends right up here at
the top point
and then i'm gonna line up the crease
that i'm flattening here right with the
center line
carefully lining it up with the center
line and then
sweeping to the outside of the squash
to complete the squash so you are
squashing it down but
really you got to be a little more
careful than just
yeah you're going to nudge it in there
coax it into
coming up correctly there so i was
squashed here i'm taking that top layer
back to the left
now i got this sort of upside down ice
cream cone or upside down kite shape
here
and now we're going to squash these guys
out here so
it's easier to flip it back over to
squash those layers
let's flip it over i'm going to lift up
one layer
the right hand side and press down you
can start to see the layer
opening right here this is what we're
going to squash right there
pressing down
and i'm lining up the crease with this
edge right here this time
this edge down here so this long crease
is lining up with just that
that edge right there so again carefully
working my way up to the top point so it
comes out
and then lining up the crease and then
pressing these
flat
so now we're going to move this top
layer back
to the right and we're gonna squash this
one
right here so let's lift it up you can
see that's where we're
we're gonna squash right in there those
layers
and gently coaxing that top of the
squash up there so
it meets the point carefully lining up
the center crease
on this flap with the main center crease
of the plane
and looking good now a double check
always
this this came out really nice and neat
down here these corners lined up really
super nice that's going to be the rear
uh corners of the plane so we're off to
a good start if that's a little bit off
you can kind of fudge your
squash folds to match but if you've
taken care to line up these creases with
the center line
on each side it should be okay so again
i've squashed it now i'm moving that top
flap back
and we've got oh boy you can start to
see
it's getting complicated look at all
that that's just amazing so
the next move we're going to do is a
complex move called a petal fold
and we're going to start our petal fold
by taking these two little raw edges
here
just to the center so we're working with
the top flap here
right just go to the center oh i missed
a little bit there can you see
i missed just a little bit down there
i'm going to straighten that
right there and just pull it up until i
can straighten it
and i'm going to do this side just
in that we're getting ready to do a
pedal fold
so we've got the two preliminary moves
done for the pedal fold
what we're going to do now is open up
those two moves
and to make a pedal fold we're going to
need to do three more creases on the
inside here so a new crease is going to
go
at the end right straight across at the
end of these two creases we made in
preparation
and then you're gonna make two creases
that go
here so we're gonna actually make a
little triangle inside there
but it's actually easier than you think
so what we're gonna do is lift this
top layer just the top layer here
of this big triangle we're lifting it up
and we're going to use as the limit
these little creases that we made here
so the limit is going to be this corner
right here in this corner right here
that's going to be the limit so we're
going to lift up this layer
and we're going to start to form this
crease that goes straight across between
the ends of those two creases
and we're just going to bend it right
there for now we're not going to
definitely make a crease
so bend it right there where this these
two creases meet this crease underneath
and the crease on top so that's going to
be a pivot point
so we're going to follow the crease on
the bottom on both sides
so we've got the crease on both sides on
the bottom
going up and now we're going to bend
this off keep moving it up
until we bring together these two sides
until they meet right here at this
center crease we're using this center
crease
uh as a way the center crease right here
you can see right there the center
crease we're using that
as a way to line up the sides that we're
moving to the inside here so we're just
kind of
wrapping this around using the center
crease
as where the point of this is going to
come out and now we want to start
definitely making the creases in here
from the center point down to the
corners here
you can kind of give it a little more
attention by pressing right there
and you can still see we haven't made
our crease across here but now we're
going to do that we're going to lift
that up
and make a crease right there now that
is the completed petal fold
and now that i've got it done it looks
so easy
but here's where we started we started
here we were like this
we folded this in we folded this in and
now you can see where the new creases
are going to go this is a valley fold
these two are mountains
and we start by lifting that up
following these creases on the bottom
those are going right where we wanted to
go
follow those on the bottom and that'll
pull the layers to the inside and then
you work that up into a point here
and then the last move is to push that
point and flatten it out
and once you've got this fancy schmancy
thing all done
[Laughter]
now the evil really starts okay we're
going to pull this apart
and we're going to grab onto these two
legs and pull
out kind of like you see my thumb's kind
of going under as i'm pulling out
and then that crease should if you can
pull it up it'll pop like that then you
just push it in there
and using the same creases no new
creases there just using the same
creases
it'll go up and inside crazy crazy crazy
but that's not as crazy as it's gonna
get we're about to get even crazier
now we're going to start making these
canards you can see how these guys
are sweeping out so we're going to lift
these points up and sweep them out and
then we're going to narrow them
eventually
so the first trick is to make sure that
you know where the point is underneath
there is kind of the braille method
that little point underneath that we
made go up we're going to use as a limit
for how much we're going to lift this up
so this guy is going to start to get
reversed we're going to change the
direction of this crease right here
we're going to pop that out and change
the direction of that crease
and we're going to lift it up but we're
going to use that point inside
as the limit for how high that goes so
our little point is right here inside
here you can kind of feel it
this layer is going to get reversed that
crease gets reversed and we're going to
lift it just for that
to where the point ends there you'll be
able to feel it pretty definitely
now the tricky thing is to to squash
this whole flat
this whole thing flat because it's just
bulging up in the air doing nothing
definite here so we're
now we're going to have to start shaping
it we've got this crease going right
where it needs to go
so from the back side from the under
layers let's work our way from the
bottom to the top
so what's going to happen at the bottom
layer
is we're going to make a crease that
goes from up in there out to this point
here so let's do that
so way up there where this point is
buried underneath
we're going to go make a crease that
goes
from that point down to this corner
right here so
this is the back side of that flap that
we reverse the direction of the main
crease on
we're just going to make a crease that
goes there and now we're going to follow
this crease here
pressing that down and you'll see that
there's some slack
happening right here and so to make the
top layer crease
we're just going to press this down try
to line up the crease with the
the bottom layer because this is a
really hard move by the way very complex
so take your time you'll need to watch
this a couple of times to probably get
it
that's okay so now it looks like that
now we do the same thing to the other
side again
the first move is reversing the
direction of this crease right here
so we're going to pop it up and
we're going to let it reverse all the
way up to where the other one
ends just make sure it's in a matching
point there
start moving it over so that we can make
the bottom layer crease here
again it's going up inside there all the
way down to this corner here
that's the first part of this assembly
and now we're going to start
pressing it flat by using this long
crease that we reversed
press it down you have to press inside
there
you can see this little triangle form
right there right there these little
triangles should be about the same size
on each side
you zoom in you'll see those little
triangles a little more definitely those
little guys form as a result of the too
much slack here so
we've created this what's going to be
the forward canard of the plane
right there so this started down like
this
we lift this up reversing that fold
and then we make this crease and then
press this
and press the top triangle back down
which forms this little triangle right
there
and of course you do that on both sides
we're not done as you can see
the canard is a little bit thinner than
the flap we've got there so now we've
got to start narrowing that flap so
step one on doing that is to take this
edge right here this raw edge
here you're going to lift this whole
flap up and over and line it up with the
right hand side there
this long crease that we just made
put that one there we're going to do the
same thing on this side this raw edge
goes against this new crease that we
just made right there
okay so this is another difficult fold
if you can make it past this you're
going all the way
i know these were hard this is even
weirder this is a little weirder so
hang in there this is where all the
magic starts to happen right here
okay we're going to unfold this lifting
the top layer
and using the end of that crease that we
just made as a reference
well you can hold that down with your
thumbnail you're going to lift the top
layer
top layer only and we're going to make a
crease that goes from
right here where this little reference
crease ended all the way out to this
corner right here
so top layer only
making the crease going out to that
corner
you can run your finger down inside
right to the corner of that pocket
there's one layer done
now we're going to lift the layer that
we left behind
swing this back down lift both of those
layers together and you can see this guy
starting to pop you're pulling that
upward
so this layer here is going to get
pulled upward we're going to make a new
crease that goes up this way
on this layer right here so those two
guys lift those together
you can see this is pulling up pulling
up pulling up so start to form a crease
that goes from right here all the way
down to this corner right here
so let's just push that over and make
that crease make sure this is staying in
the right position
making that crease and then you'll make
a new crease up here
as that comes together now i missed a
little bit you can see that i missed
just a little bit right here
i'm just a little below that mark that's
okay don't worry about that
just try to get it in the same spot for
this side it's not critical
but if you miss a little bit it's way
more important to get this whole
assembly kind of looking like this
and this corner ends up being kind of
important for the looks of the plane
later so
now that you've got that going we're
just going to lift this up and tuck that
underneath
and there we go you can kind of see that
now that canard is really starting to
form there
so let's do the same thing to this side
we're going to unfold that
we're going to use our thumbnail as a
limit there and i'm going to cheat it
down just so it ends up in the same
place as my other fold
there we go now those corners are
matching you'll never
see the error okay i'm folding out to
the outside edge there the outside
corner that is
making that crease trying to get it to
line up with the mistake that i made
before
okay there's the under layer done now
i'm going to swing that back down and
lift both of those at the same time
which is going to cause this layer to
start pulling up
so lay that flat continue to pull that
layer up and make the new crease
from this corner right here all the way
down to this corner right here
rolling that over getting that corner in
place
flattening it and
flattening this part right up here so i
didn't it wasn't perfect
it's a little bit off but you know what
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna sweat that
that's a that's it looks like a giant
error right here right now
um but you know what it's not going to
affect the plane flight
that's one where we're just going to go
that's between you and i
we're not going to tell anybody about
that one we got a little bit of a
mistake right there
we're going to straighten it up on the
next move that we're going to do here
this is where this is how we're going to
hide that one
so now we're going to start to move
these flaps back to the outside
and i'm going to fold this over i'm
going to lift this top flap
i'm gonna fold this over just right at
that corner
so it's gonna go from this corner all
the way down to this corner and moving
this flap back to the outside
there we go i'm gonna do the same thing
on this side
the corner from this only i'm not gonna
go to that corner i'm gonna go right
here where this guy ends right here
okay so moving that back out i'm gonna
go just short
this is where i'm gonna level this guy
up right here just short
and right there where that one matches
and then i'm going to go down to this
corner
and that my friend is how you hide a
tiny folding error
those corners came out in the right
place and
since oh i could let that layer slip
just a little bit
as i was playing games there so i'm
gonna
remake that holding that in place okay
there we go
that's better now that's laying flat
we're going to do a little reverse fold
move here because it'll lock together
and hold together a little bit more
nicely
if i instead of just leaving that loose
like that i'm going to tuck this under a
little bit so i've got two layers kind
of compressing it together so
a reverse fold works like this we're
going to unfold that
we're going to follow the bottom layer
and reverse this top layer here
so this edge is going to end up going
the different direction that's
why it's called reversible we're
actually going to reverse this big
crease here
we're going to recrease this a little
bit right here but that's not the
reversing part this
is the reversing part i'm flattening
that
following the bottom layer pushing that
big crease to the
all the way up inside there and i've
reversed it so it was down here like
this
and kind of like closing a milk carton
i'm pushing that in
following this bottom layer is going to
go the same direction it's going and
this top layer you can see it was
like that and then it's going to turn
into a mountain fold as i push this
layer in
and reverse that that crease there this
turns into a mountain bowl
okay that's one side done no new creases
here we're just manipulating the old
creases so i'm going to
make this reverse fold here i'm just
going to reverse this little part
i'm lifting this up pressing this crease
that's going to reverse i'm pressing it
flat pressing it to the inside
and it goes swings out like that so now
all we have to do is a little bit of
shaping what we're going to start with
is folding the plane in half
right down the center line let's flip it
over so the relatively smooth side
is up we're going to rotate it so the
nose is pointed left
and then right down the old pipeline
here just following the existing crease
now when you're making the wing crease
the cool thing here
about this plane is that you can see
this old style dart the classic dart is
kind of in the heart of this thing and
it's populated by all this other
high-tech stuff but to get the
old-school dart look we're going to use
this
edge and bring it right down to the
center crease
that we just made really easy to do with
the nose you have
tons of room to line up right here at
the nose and so you'll
get that going that direction and then
bring it down and you have to play a
little bit of peekaboo here
with that center crease you can see it
pretty easily right there i'm going to
move in a little bit you can see it even
better here
you can see it right here you're going
to line up right there
and then just do the best you can as it
goes back toward the rear of the plane
so
get it go in the right direction kind of
start pressing it and then
go ahead and start creasing it sweeping
left sweeping right
and that's looking pretty good let's
flip it over we'll make the other wing
match of course
so now the important thing is you've got
these two rear corners on every paper
airplane
that's what you want to pay attention to
those two rear corners this
and this and of course we're going to
use our lineup right here again
let's get the nose going just going to
bend it over we're not going really
going to make a fine crease here yet
we're just going to bend it into
position
and then continue to bend this over now
you're going to carefully line up these
rear corners
and start making a bend in there before
you make a real crease
get it lined up start to press a little
bit harder
and then we're going to sweep toward the
back of the plane
make sure those corners are staying
lined up as you sweep toward the back of
the plane i got a little bit of air
going there
there we go back on track sweep to the
back of the plane and then
start sweeping to the front of the plane
get that lock down in position
now your canards could be a little bit
off here you can see it's not perfect
but that's okay what you're going to do
to level this thing up to even this up
is you're going to make a crease for
these winglets now look at the way the
crease goes right down
the winglet so that it stays in a
straight line right here
that's what you're looking for and
you're looking for it to be parallel
with the main wing crease
and in a straight line right there so if
you look at it
right down the barrel here you can see
those that's
one straight line right down the
winglets that's what you're shooting for
so let's start with the rear winglet and
we're going to use this corner right
here as kind of a reference and you can
see
the angle that we're aiming for right
here
move that up a little bit that looks
pretty good
okay i'm gonna go ahead and make that
that looks pretty tight
pretty correct now we're gonna make this
we're just gonna continue on just like
we're making one
solid crease up there we're just going
to continue this line right through here
and we'll do the best we can to line
this up and make it even
i think that's giving me a little bit of
trouble right there so i'm going to back
up and
take one more run out of here
that looks pretty good okay
so that came up pretty straight it's a
straight line between those creases
right there
that's looking good and no matter how
straight it came out when we do the
other side
we're going to make these layers match
and so the key thing here when we flip
it over to the other side
you start you know paying attention more
to that bottom layer
you do want it to be parallel here but
really what you're doing is you want to
make this wing match the other wing so
roll it carefully roll it over until you
can just
line up with the edge below so what
you're doing is just
just carefully rolling over and double
checking underneath there that you're
lining it up
right on top of that other edge and then
as a last check
just take a look at this this edge here
so that all looks pretty good
lining up that edge that comes out
pretty parallel and
what we're gonna do here is now do the
same thing with the front winglet
just get that going looks like we're
pretty close in line with this
okay looking good winglets are done
they're folded anyway now it's all about
the adjusting and there's some really
delicious adjusting with regard to this
plane so the first thing we're going to
do
unlike most great paper airplanes not a
lot of dihedral angle here
we're going to set the wings fairly flat
because these winglets
are going to add what's called effective
dihedral they're going to
cause the wingtip vortices to shed
really cleanly
and they're going to really help the
plane resist rolling left or rolling
right
and as long as these are straight up and
down what you've got here is
effective dihedral from these upward
swept wing tips
both ways it also gives it really good
structural integrity
all the way down the length of the plane
and then
what this plane is known for is being
stall resistant
and to add the stall resistance what
we're going to do is increase
the angle of incidence that is the
amount of tilt
on this forward wing now stalls are
caused
by two things if the plane is flying too
slowly the airflow just can't follow the
shape of the wing
so the coanda effect doesn't have a
chance to
have its way to follow the surface of
the wing so
if too slow a flight is happening the
airflow comes unglued that's called a
stall
and if the plane is tilted up too much
with regard to the airflow
if it's just trying to to angle up and
fly like that too much of the airflow is
going like this
the airflow can't easily follow the
shape of the wing
and so the airflow comes unglued and
no more downward uh
vectoring off the trailing edge of the
plane and therefore no more lift
it's a loss of lift so stall is really
just a loss of lift a loss of
laminar flow over the wing and
it's not making any more lift and we
call that a stall
so what we're doing here is
intentionally making the little wings
stall
by adding more angle of incidence here
tilting that upward more
so when the plane the whole plane is
close to stall phase
because this little wing is tilted up a
little bit more it's going to stall
first that'll drop the nose down
which now causes the plane to pick up
speed and reduces the angle of incidence
on the main wing here
so that it never gets the stall phase so
it's a really tricky little design
you've got a little bit of upward sweep
here on the canard
and then what we're going to do of
course because it is a glider in an
engine-less plane
we're going to add some up elevator
right back here
right there that is a really
great looking plane pull back out just a
little bit give yourself
a little bit of room there to swing this
guy around show you every angle of this
guy look at that
what a gorgeous looking plane you can
see that old style dart
front to back there really cool
forward canard making it stall resistant
and then that
that nice broad rear wing there gorgeous
plane will fly pretty good distance but
here's the issue with this guy look at
all of these layers under here
that's really going to cause a lot of
drag underneath the plane all the air
flow
does is get tripped up on all those
little layers everywhere and so
it's slowing it down that's a drag
inducing thing all those layers
even all these layers right here at the
nose see all that thickness happening
right there
it's just not quite as clean as it needs
to be
to get a world record going but what a
fantastic looking plane the super canard
you